hello um as you can see we are missing a
couple people uh i had to take over and
of course there were uh technical
difficulties turns out though pc just
needed a restart and that was it
took us took me 25 minutes to figure
that out but anyway
i'm your host jake decker today this is
episode 158 of gamespot after dark and
joining me is curt and davina hi
greetings salutations happy to be here
thank you for being here thank you for
being patient
and jess howard hi um excited to be here
thank you for being here drove in
drove in the great the great lengths you
go to drive a car to hang out with an md
office of people yeah
the hour and 20 minute drive that
because it's from sacramento to san
francisco took me two and a half
nice very fun
um keep us updated if anything seems off
let me know and i can try to fiddle with
it again hopefully it won't take uh too
long but this is gonna be a somewhat
paired back episode because uh we're
missing a lot of people jean-luc is off
uh lucy is getting something important
for her work travel
and tamora is meeting someone very
important too important for this
but anyway
jess you've been on game spot after dark
before yeah i think a couple times i
think once before i was hired a while
ago okay and then once right after i was
hired okay so we don't necessarily
need to do the whole introduction thing
because i remember when you were on
before
but when was last time you're on you
want to give people an update uh last
time i was on was december
um
i don't know what has happened i had a
baby
that's a pretty big update i had a baby
yeah
no big deal no big deal just a little
baby um
yeah i don't i don't know um i'm tired
i'm sleep deprived um
because i have a baby and because you
had to drive two and a half hours
yeah that's it
in a room while jay pretended like he
knew what he was doing as i ripped apart
this room turns out i just needed the
old restart but what is life if not
sitting in a room pretending you know
what you're doing
so we have an episode planned obviously
uh first we're gonna start off with what
we've been playing as usual
um
this is an interesting one because kurt
you're playing a bunch of mobile games
yes for video yes you probably don't
want to talk too much about them or do
you ah i mean i would i will actually
there's maybe there's maybe one or two
i'm willing to talk about
uh
i
so for context i don't play mobile games
and there's not even really like an
intention behind that i've just never
been in a place where
the mar the mobile market seemed to
appeal to me like like there weren't
murmurs of games that seemed like
interesting of course there's stuff like
monument valley that's
made ripples in the medium of it but
otherwise i've just always i just i just
haven't given it a chance so the the the
point of this video that i'm working on
is to stop myself from playing
everything else i packed up my consoles
i unplugged them
and i'm only playing mobile games for a
week straight wow but the intent to find
what i'm confident could be my next
favorite game because it would be so
ignorant of me to think that like
there isn't something great in the sea
of hundreds of thousands of mobile games
over there
so anyways that's just the context for
it but what i've been playing
i had a tough time the first day
okay
and then i was like you know what i
gotta like let me search for story just
search for story because i like story
games yeah i like visual novels
put story in the search bar uh in the in
the old iphone app store and all i got
was choose your own adventure romance
novels one of which is just called dills
nice oh okay i downloaded it and it's a
series of books you can choose from wow
one of them was called waking up
pregnant and that's what i chose so i'm
playing that i've been there
[Laughter]
written by just hollering yeah
so yeah but otherwise i did like in my
in my journey to find uh things i'm
enjoying i started playing florence oh
okay
that's really i was gonna ask if you
would check that one out because that is
the mobile game really so i i don't know
i've seen florence i know of florence i
like i even know some of the notoriety
behind the developer of it um but it was
like i was scrolling through it was like
299 i was getting sick of dealing with
free ads and games specifically hidden
object hidden object games
uh they'll like spoon feed you ads for
two minutes straight until you just find
like a vase in the midst of a [ __ ]
you know
corner of a room um and i was like you
know what 2.99 is nothing that's that's
less than a cup of coffee i'll take a
chance and i got florence and holy hot
schnikeys i think this is like i like i
get it so that's that's one of the
that's the experience i'm like playing
through right now where it's like
actually like
i'm starting to see how the this this
device that if
used well can actually utilize like the
intent of something really really really
well are you going to force yourself to
play something a little
more mobily like clash of clans or
something or the refresher
things that you know you would be into
that's the point is that i'm trying to
find things that i know that will speak
to me like okay it's not that like i'm
trying to expose myself to like a
certain corner of mobile games
just for the sake of it it's just like
no the point is like i know of games
like clash of clans i know of games like
angry bird i know like those things and
like kind of their short attention span
sort of like design
and like no i'm looking for something
that's actually like using the intent of
a phone of a tab of like this device in
your hand
um with like
a sense of like artistic deliberateness
yeah so florence is such a good option
for that because it is such a tactile
game like it works so well so it's like
changing things constantly and and the
way that like i if i'm not that far in
it i think i'm like on act three
yes there are um but yeah no i so no to
answer your question i'm not going for
that i'm looking for kurt games to play
yeah
i would give you recommendations except
i've also never really dabbled in mobile
games other than florence although i did
have i just chose that one
it's a good choice uh out of the blue i
did start playing apple what is it apple
arcade games for a while and i and i
think it lasted a day or two was like
included without tv that was the next
step i was going to take yeah i'd be
like it seems like there's some good
stuff but i can't be bothered it's not
that those games aren't
good because there's a lot of really
good stuff on there it's more that i'm
playing enough games right now and i
don't i don't want to add more things to
the rotation that's why i had to put
everything away yeah the only way i'm
going to do this is if i like take a
break from playing console games
put my 3ds away which is the really
tough one to pack up because i play that
every night before i go to bed
so yeah dang
just hotel desk over and over and over
again well i that is actually no
that's i have like a yearly like
replay of hotel dusk so that was coming
up but no i'm still trying to finish up
flower sun and rain like okay uh
[Music]
the like part of the silver case suda
games and like i just have not finished
it yet but that's like my go-to fall
asleep at night game
okay then hotel desk again nice so
oh i would say so an interesting type of
mobile game that maybe you should try
there are games and they're usually
atomic games or atomic games so like
they are you know like romance games
right
but they will use the phone in an
interesting way as far as like
i don't know like having setups where it
seems like you're getting text messages
from different characters and things
like that and they're really interesting
i'm trying to remember some of the ones
that i've dabbled with there's one
that's like during a zombie apocalypse
like thing and it's called i think it's
called dangerous fellows or something
there's i know there's another game like
that that i remember is it emily
something emily oh emily is away is it
emily is away maybe it's because it's
the aim one mystery game where you like
go through someone else's like i think
text messages and phones no they're
actually texting you like it is amazing
i think you're supposed to set up
notifications and more played one of
them i love that mystic messenger is
another one too it's like a romance game
where you're interacted with that way
and i think that they're really
inventive you know like i usually i kind
of fall off of them as much as i like
these like silly you know romance games
but it's it's really cool what they're
doing
yeah that's see that's the thing as i
have enough like i have a thing
where i'm like obsessed with the intent
of like how a developer uses
a console or device or a thing with the
intent of that thing so i feel like
sometimes even i like that's one of the
reasons why like like i don't have much
like a thing for pc gaming because it's
like
this all across the board swiss army
knife of a way to play games totally
fine totally cool i get it but there's
something about like my obsession with a
game like sea man for dreamcast that's
like that game cannot exist in any other
place than it did on dreamcast hotel
dusk on the nintendo ds that game can't
exist in any other way than i did on the
ds because of how it was designed for
the ds so i'm on the hunt for games that
feel so specific to being made for a
phone so ideas of like someone texting
me yeah like a game or that way like yes
that's that's what i'm looking for like
that's what i want so i'm easing into it
like deliberately went in with no
recommendations i'm trying to like see
what it's like for someone to go in like
totally blind bare bones basically know
nothing over the past like seven some
years of mobile marketing and now we're
ruining for you by giving you
suggestions no i think it's okay it's
like i think i'm like this is day three
and i think i'm at the point where it's
like i think i need a little little
outside influence because i play
florence i know the minute i finish
florence i'm like well now what do i do
yeah florence is so good i'm glad you
played that one have you did you do
sayonara wild hearts
no and i'm kind of hesitant because it
is a console game as well that's what i
was going to say that's one that like i
love it i played it on mobile but it
doesn't need to be played on mobile so
it doesn't quite fit in line with and
the developers samogo have done like
are have done phenomenal mobile games
before in the past most of them haven't
played but your walk was a game they
made that started as a mobile game then
i eventually played on pc absolutely i
absolutely love your walk so i will
eventually go down the rabbit hole i
know yeah
no that's what i'm playing nice well i'm
excited to see your video because
you know anything that really stands out
i might want to check out it's probably
just gonna be dil's waking up
i named my my the female protagonist i
play as as crut so sexy jeff is always
like crut i wanna touch you and
also you have to pay it's a free game
but they're the micro transactions are
baked into the choices you make so if
you want like the good sexy fun times
you gotta pay for it yeah that's how a
lot of those are yeah like episodes is
the really big one that a lot of people
play and it's
yeah you'll have it's you have to pay to
do anything in it yeah all the worst
choices are free yeah
it'll be like it'll seriously be like
how do you want to dress for your day
and it's like a trash bag a paper bag a
really expensive gown pay five dollars
and it's like oh my god i had no idea
yeah there was one there's one option in
the scene when crutch goes in to find
her one night stand jeff and say
i'm pregnant she has like sickness in
front of him uh and you have a choice to
be like run for the bathroom 17 diamonds
uh like you grabbed the garbage can 15
diamonds of which those are the things
you did before puke on his shoes freeze
i mean this is the best yeah i was going
to say that seems more entertaining like
i want to play through just the worst
things he could possibly still get very
lovely about it he was just like it's
okay i'm the ceo of this company i'll
take care of everything so there's still
a lot of zeros act you know they're just
like oh you threw up on my eight
thousand dollar shoes yeah i'm jeff oh
getting in the same elevator with you
with my five thousand dollar suit what's
the line i think that was in fifty
shades of grey right yeah yeah
jess how about you what have you been
playing um so i reviewed cult of the
lamb so i played thank you um i played a
lot of that and it's really fun i i mean
i did the review for our site so wasn't
that your first review it was my first
video i've done a couple other indie
games and both of the other indie games
i didn't like too much so i feel like
that's why i kept quiet about them
because i don't like to like you know
put people in blast but yeah i wasn't as
into those ones but this is like i i
loved cult of the lamb it was a lot of
fun
um
but i know that i la i listened to last
week's episode of game sweat after dark
and i know that it was talked about
extensively so i won't focus on that um
i also have been playing a little bit of
two point campus
um
i i started playing it on console though
and i do have to say that you know it's
cool that it's i think it's on game pass
and that's why i was playing it on
console um but those types of games i
really just need to play on pc um tycoon
games and simulation games they just it
does not work for me um on console i
felt like i was just constantly like
clicking buttons trying to get to like
where i wanted to get to in the menu
because it's so menu heavy um
so yeah i don't know
uh and then i beat stray which i know is
super delayed because that came out oh i
haven't been i haven't beaten it either
okay all right well cool um i don't know
if i will i don't know if i will either
that's kind of how i felt about it too i
i didn't really have like a strong urge
to play it um but i was like
uh i think this game is only like four
or five hours long and it seems kind of
cute and i got a new cat and i was like
i wonder if he's going to react to it
yeah
oh he yeah he loved it honestly it was
didn't give a [ __ ] really neither one of
my cats cared at all oh so did that kind
of kill it for you because no not in the
slightest i okay no like that game i
don't know if i like that game yeah i i
kind of feel the same way but while i
was playing it i felt that i needed to
have a cat to fully enjoy the game they
didn't care at all but yeah they
provided you a cat no i was like hanging
me out yeah
i was like even trying to like gesture
both lily and megatron like look there's
a there's a game there's a you thing we
need we need to make twitter content
come on yes like i need to be cool turns
like a pageant mom like exactly
neither one of them cared megatron was
like i'm gonna go lay on my back and in
the sunlight and lily it was just like
i'm an old lady i don't care yeah
neither one of them cared yeah i i think
the game seems very well made like i
played the first hour or so and i was
enjoying it uh i i don't know i just
didn't didn't grab me i guess as much as
it seemed a lot of other people i will
say i did see some people saying like oh
people only like it because it's got a
cat in it and it's like
yeah
but it's got a cat like
this game doesn't exist without the cat
so it's such a weird argument to make
like it is that's the same people only
like tomb raider because lara croft's in
it i only like games that have humans in
it
that's it
no it was uh i like we don't to go too
much into it but i i was uh i think i
agree it's a very extremely well made
game it's very well realized and put
together and it feels like whole it
feels holistic in that way um i was just
getting bored it i just you know i also
kept running into this thing this design
thing that bugs me where uh it's the
whole idea of where when it's the easy
way to put is like finding the key
before the door yes and it often was
finding objects and things before i had
actually found like the puzzle that they
were supposed to be or like the scenario
that was used and it kind of was like
kind of like deflating in a way being
like oh i already have like all this
because i went on my own merry way and
was doing cat stuff
that's interesting that you bring that
up i wonder
from a developer perspective or from
like a designer perspective
would you prefer your players to find
the key before the door or do you want
them to find the door before the key i
was i was always under the or i felt i
always felt that's like you're presented
with the
obstacle you're presented with a thing
you can't get around yeah and then it's
like your ability to like problem solve
and figure out what it is you need to do
to get through it and too often
like very early in the game like when
you have to stop a fan a propeller you
find the bucket i know you're tired
that's exactly what i was thinking find
the bucket like on the ground and then
you and you're like i was like but if i
was presented with a propeller like damn
how do i get through this and then i see
the bucket i'm like oh my god i'm a
genius i was i was robbed at that genius
moment i guess when i think of kian door
my brain automatically goes to zelda and
when i find a small key in zelda i don't
really care if i've seen the door yet
but because i know
i'm going to find the door but that's
not really but sometimes finding the key
first and not knowing what door goes to
is interesting that's true yes so like
sometimes you have a bunch of doors and
you have a bunch of keys yes but that
may not make sense and then there's like
that and of itself is like a puzzle and
usually i feel like with zelda a lot of
times too it's like you open and you get
whatever like the new weapon or the key
and like part of the challenge then
becomes like the obstacle to still get
to that door you know what i mean so
it's like there's still that element of
challenge because i feel the same as you
like it wasn't i never felt challenged
by it and any of the extra things that
you could do where you were looking for
things like finding the sheet music um
it's completely optional it really
doesn't feel like it yeah if you're
doing all that an achievement yeah like
in the guy will play music but yeah
but yeah it's a really stylish game um i
do i've seen a lot of feedback though um
online about
how it's another one of those games that
uses like very asian-centric locations
and like has that feel of being like it
but like
there's no asia you know i mean there's
like no representation yeah you got
robots in uh in you know cool cool garbs
and stuff yeah right so it's like that's
one thing that i've seen where you know
people are
more upset about and i get that like i
totally get that because i got that vibe
while playing it i was like okay they're
using a lot of set pieces but i feel
like there's not really any like culture
history here which can be a little you
know
um but yeah i i
i liked it it was very much like
an average game maybe i i don't know
dude it's a it's it was a budget title
like it's like i mean it's one of those
another you want to uh base anything off
of like how much it is i would say but
it's like it's one of those things where
it's like it's a five hour sum game it's
like
i'm pretty sure i was like very close to
the end of it if it had been any longer
i would have stopped to be honest
i'm pretty sure like if i play it for
like 30 minutes more i might finish it
but um well you can't now you packed up
your consoles yeah you're screwed
they're all zipped up in a duffel bag it
feels kind of gruesome
uh jordan calls us a bunch of cat haters
and that we need to drink i have two
cats i love it and i'm like
love them like dude like i will kill a
person look at the camera i will tell
them yeah tell them megatron and lily
are
an extension of my identity they're like
daughters they're things that i love
they're things that are matter to me a
game does not def whether my opinion on
a cat game does not align with how much
i care about my sexy
felines i i probably just don't like
cats
or that no i like cats cats are fine i
guess i exist somewhere in the middle
because i really like cats but i would i
don't think i'd call jonesy a sexy
feline so i do i objectify mine that's
up to you
[Laughter]
uh well
i don't have a whole lot to talk about
because
uh
i both the games i've been playing i
can't talk about yet sweet i can say
what i'm playing at least one of them i
the last of us part one but i can't
say anything about it which is strange
because the game's already
you know people played this yeah you
know talk about the old one yeah talk
about the old one and not bring yeah
that'd be tough i don't think i could do
that
uh i have been playing a very strange
game it's not it's not even that it's
strange uh it is a game that i typically
wouldn't play called way of the hunter
and it is a hunting game now
i have never played a hunting game
before apart from a game called hunt
call of the wild or something and the
fun part of that game wasn't the hunting
it was just [ __ ] around with friends
because it had multiplayer and you could
get go-karts and run people over and
stuff you know all the stuff you want to
do in a hunting game
but
this game uh
is is is very meditative
i i'm a big fan of that i'm an absolute
disaster when it comes to hunting i
can't i can't hit anything i don't know
how to properly hunt i feel like i'm 200
meters away and all the animals near me
are spooked but
the game looks so good and it's so
serene i'm just walking through fields
checking out i like those checking out
the birds that are flying by watching
the deer there's also photography modes
if you don't want to actually hunt
you can use a camera pokemon snap
exactly and then just one around this
giant world that it that is pretty
gorgeous there's different maps you can
go to you can even do it with a friend
although it's pretty buggy okay um
[Music]
yeah it's
it's it's interesting i don't normally
play games like this but i've been
enjoying the serene
relaxing nature of it i think it's
because i've been playing a lot of
player unknowns battlegrounds which i
talked about last week because i'm doing
a dumb video
uh
and after the high intensity moments of
that it's nice to just go to this other
world and there's watch a stream i think
it was that one whatever when you like
hunt what's the hunt one hunter call of
the wild
world one yeah so i always i'm not i
have no desire to play a game where i
hunt innocent animals um or haunt
animals i guess i should say uh but i've
i've always been like but that game
looks like i like the idea of being like
in an open world and just like uh taking
your time
uh but trying to track down something if
it was like
not a deer that'd be sweet yeah but i
like the idea of this i mean what i'm
saying is i'm a big fan of just like
existing world games yeah yeah the the
the
that's kind of what it feels like to me
like i am just
taking in the scenery walking really
slow checking things out there's not a
whole lot to do there's some interesting
encyclopedia bits that'll tell you about
the area you're in the animals that
you're hunting and like how to ethically
hunt which is interesting depending on
how you look at it
but the the idea in this game is that
like the hunting is for um sustenance
you know like yeah if you really want to
get into like how animals are treated
and stuff like
a hunt i'd rather be hunted as an animal
than being locked in a cage and
treated like [ __ ] but that's that's
another conversation
um
but yeah
i don't know it's it's it's neat
yeah it's
about all i have to say i i haven't
played a whole lot uh it's really buggy
uh
i know some people have i mean i haven't
run into any issues apart from stuff
i've had in multiplayer
um but i know i was watching i think
it's acg did a review and he liked it i
think he said it was a buy but then he
updated his statement because there was
a wind
sound effect bed that was over
everything that he couldn't get rid of
no matter how many times he reinstalled
uh like loaded in different saves just
no matter where he was just a very loud
wind noise that ultimately let him
making a video to say i don't recommend
this game anymore until they've got this
sorted so it sounds like it was pretty
annoying i don't know if they fixed it i
think the game came out a day ago or two
days ago so like there was a day one
patch or something could always just
play on a bad laptop with like a loud
fan you won't even know yeah i mean
people like white noise um yeah uh
someone in chat sorry i don't know how
to pronounce your name [ __ ] haiyuga says
yeah acg was the one who posted that
review
um
and no it has the art of war hasn't
helped me hunt animals at all
um
yeah i wish i could talk about the other
stuff but i just can't it's fine yeah
it's fine next week
next week next week will be an
interesting one you can just like face
away from the camera and just mouth it
to us and we'll just look really excited
yeah
okay
no i'm not even gonna do that it's not
worth it somebody will like catch it in
a reflection
yeah yeah
that's what they think oh no
uh so that's
basically what we've been playing
uh
we have
a couple topics here that i threw down i
don't know if uh you guys had a look at
some of these absolutely not decide on
the fly i only have two actually but
then we have a question of the week for
maria which was brought to you by the
gamespot discord server if you're not in
it be sure to join
um
the first one is i figured
we should probably talk about embracer
group
i like woke up this morning and i feel
like almost like
exhausted by the amount of stuff that
embrace your spine to the point where
it's like i'm not i don't even know how
to react to it anymore and i didn't
understand that the lord of the rings
one today because i was like what do you
mean they bought
lord of the rings it's like what does
that mean i was like maybe they just
bought the rights from like ea so they
can make
games yeah but then i was like
no they bought
the rights to lord of the rings yeah
yeah
where where is embracer getting all this
money so
i have no idea uh so for those who don't
know the embracer group is a holding
company i have this written down here's
a holding company and that means rather
than producing something it has
financial stake in many smaller
companies companies obviously i'm
simplifying it like crazy there's a lot
more to it but i believe it is a swedish
company
sounds right uh and
they've been in headlines a lot because
they purchased a bunch of video game
they're building the biggest library of
like complete video games yeah it's it's
pretty insane there's a pie chart um
that you can find that's even bigger now
technically but it shows like how much
sony owns in terms of the game space how
much microsoft owns in the game space
and then how much embracer owns and it
is huge like outnumbering 10 cent
outnumbering pretty much everything
um and this adds to it and it's not only
games like they have uh
uh i think dark horse comics they own as
well didn't know that and i think
i think they might have stakes in some
movie studios as well or at least
something because aren't they trying to
make like a saints row movie i feel like
i heard about well that's i think that's
what i was getting to earlier i become
like almost exhausted by seeing a bracer
oh yeah to the point where like i feel
like if i i could have almost went my
day without with like not even
remembering that i saw that they bought
lord of the rings together they'd be
like
how do you why huh the tolkien estate
was just like
yeah there's an undisclosed amount right
did they say how much oh i i think they
have to reveal it eventually right
they didn't oh i didn't see a number
they didn't i didn't see one of the
headlines or anything i think that's
what was shocking to me is like i was
surprised that they sold
i was surprised it wasn't already
purchased by someone like that i guess
like i i would have figured amazon would
have been like yeah we'll take that
right now because we're doing rings of
power or whatever but i i don't know how
that works but i don't know i thought
lucy
the conversation lucy james would come
in she's she's got it running through
her veins yeah
well she's not here so what's she going
to do
deal with it let's talk about how much
lord of the rings sucks yeah no i
i've been trying to read the books only
isn't that the only blu-rays you've been
watching
well yeah so when i moved into my new
apartment i didn't have internet
uh but i had blu-rays and i recently
purchased the
4k blu-ray collection of lord of the
rings the uh director's cuts which i had
never seen before in fact i'd only seen
all of those movies once in theaters and
that was a long time ago so with no
internet i figured i'd watch lord of the
rings and i got about
halfway through two towers meaning i got
through the first disc of two towers
because there's two for each movie
because
of course there is
but yeah
yeah i i
there is some
there is was an interesting quote that
did come out of this though um to make
it look like i have been preparing
somewhat for this
uh steven tottillo tweeted embracer ceo
ceo lars wing of fours on what game
games industry trends he's seeing
a bit back to basics i would say let's
talk about blockchain and nfts thank god
i prefer to talk about real games and
experiences
so i mean that's just a quote i don't
know
it's hard to say what that could mean
but hopefully
that means that these acquisitions will
at least lead to games that are a little
more
i don't know standard
single player not
not and they won't be jumping on the nft
train and stuff yeah uh i mean they also
there was like also it wasn't their
talks of likes already being like yeah
we're gonna do spin off who are the
rings films
wasn't that a part of the cover really
that's what i saw see i didn't read much
of the lord of the rings stuff because i
don't really care i mean there's it's i
mean the thing is with lord of the rings
like there's a lot there
um that you can pull from
um but there's still a lot of fill you
have to do in the midst of like lore and
stories that are talked about like yeah
there's like there's a lot to pull from
it's just it's gonna
involve you know filling a lot of gaps
and stuff like that
um
but i just don't you know
um
i have no stake in this conversation if
i'm being honest i'm exhausted by
everything all the time if they if they
if they balloon it out into star wars a
fight and marvel fight
i'm so happy for those who are excited
about it i guess it's a bit reassuring
to hear that quote just because like so
they also bought limited run um which
makes like the physical copies of you
know limited edition games and stuff
like that um and
i don't know i guess if they have kind
of this old school mentality on back to
basic and i'm just like i don't feel
great about this news but i'm just like
for the sake of you know
having some sort of positive angle on
this if they're getting back into that
and they're buying limited run games
like maybe they have intent on you know
making different games more widely
accessible which is great because
accessibility is like like or i guess
not accessibility in the sense that you
might be thinking when talking games
like the possibility of being able to
play it yeah being able to play them
yeah exactly annoying it's frustrating
especially unless you know you want to
ram it or emulate it but even then it's
like it's not
it goes back to what i was saying
earlier it's like it's not the way that
those things were intended to be played
but yeah embracer is building the
biggest
game library the entire build the
biggest like physical game library
basically buying every single physical
game that was ever made you know which
is like
not great but i guess at the if you want
to you know for preservation i think
yeah for preservation yeah that's an
interesting thing i i i i just don't
know how much of
like i'm just not versed enough oh yeah
it's also
i don't know
big media conglomerates aren't always
they don't always operate with uh ethics
and other people in mind necessarily so
i i definitely get the skepticism i'm
definitely skeptical about the direction
that's heading
but
i i don't know it's weird it feels like
he they came out of nowhere too just all
of a sudden literally was announced at
like 9 30 last night like just um
i mean this is me being ignorant are
they the folks who also bought like tomb
raider yes
crystal dynamics
uh thq nordic okay so they own
that that came with like 11 studios i
think such a bizarre one they're the
people playing monopoly who are like
getting all the orange properties and
stuff on that side like that's really
what it feels like it's just buying like
these mid to lower like things that you
don't necessarily think about as much
but like you add it all up crystalline
that's a lot crystal dynamics was a
surprise that i was just surprised that
square was like peace i'm not
yeah okay
square enix didn't seem to treat its
western studios
i think they were pretty ready to
offload uh square enix especially after
marvel avengers but
i am surprised in the sense that they
offloaded some very popular ips you know
that's really what i'm worried but but
even i remember when tomb raider 2013
came out and it sold like five million
copies and square eggs put out a release
yeah we were a little disappointed with
the performance of tomb raider it's like
what what were you expecting like
that seems pretty good to me yeah but i
think that game went through a lot of
internal
reboots and stuff not reboots but it's
been a lot of time in development for
what i remember yeah um but i do think
what you said is interesting though
because even though they have such a big
piece of the pie i feel like a lot of
the studios they own apart from you know
a handful are smaller
like double a studios
you know like
sure microsoft has less studios by
comparison but a lot of those studios
are huge yeah and you know they're
making halo and stuff which
is
a giant game that that embracer doesn't
really have
it com
something that stands toe to toe with it
you know which i mean like if you're
coming at it from like an investment
point of view which is like what that
company is first and foremost like makes
sense it's like you don't want to put
all your eggs in one basket so it's
better to have a lot of you know smaller
studios doing a lot of different types
of things
because that way you know if
tides change and if they're looking at
you know what i mean like i i don't know
like if there's a direction the market's
going in and like different studios that
are doing well while others are kind of
going under
like
makes sense
but the lord of the rings but lord of
the rings
lord of the rings like that's the one
i'm like oh okay yeah you can buy that
yeah i guess so you can buy anything
like how how old is lord of the rings
isn't it like after 100 years it's
technically public domain anyway but i
know disney
no it's not 100. well i know disney has
done a very good job of extending that
timeline
and extending it good lawyers cause
isn't mickey mouse supposed to be up for
public domain soon and disney's like
wait a second wait a second we don't
want
weird wasn't that what happened
yeah winning the pool's public domain
now as of earlier this year yeah which
is why there's that atrocious looking
horror baby winnie the pooh horror film
that's being made wait what yeah yeah
it looks real bad it has it has like
that thanks killing vibe to it
you haven't seen this well i've seen
thanks killing and i know that's what i
was saying i'm talking about the the
winnie the pooh horror film i have not
seen oh i was like i was hoping it was a
fever dream that i just was just gonna
maybe it was if i didn't know wishful
thinking right
jess confirms you though like all things
i wake up in the morning and i look at
the news and i try to forget
i just try to pick and choose what's in
so yeah
i just don't look at the news not
working in games for a while was kind of
nice because i just didn't pay attention
to things a game would come out and i'd
be like cool guess it's out maybe i'll
play it maybe i won't maybe i won't even
look at a review yeah maybe i'll do that
a lot too maybe i'll just take a risk
yeah i'll just get what i want to play
but yeah walk in the wild side
all three of your viewers are sitting
here right now maybe you just shouldn't
listen maybe just maybe just get a game
don't look at the review but you should
look at
jess's review for call one thing over
and over just refresh the page
[Music]
we gotta get those those pages those
page views up
uh well
i think we've talked about embracer
unless current there's anything you want
to add i know you feel pretty
impassioned about this news i want to
take a nap okay
you can do it have fun
i want my bed to embrace me
yes
embrace her embrace embrace me and your
biggest library of games arms and just
so i could look at the dreamcast section
sounds nice taking a little nap like i
just imagined like a plastic cases oh no
see i just i imagine like a very nice
library with like brick and like wood
and a fireplace but it's just it's just
video games you just take a little nap
right there next to the fire did you
did you stop at our little game library
we have over no i honestly so i was
scared to look around i was like i don't
know where i'm allowed to go
you could go anywhere on this floor yeah
you could kiss you could like throw
stuff yeah like yeah throw stuff break
some windows well maybe you don't break
windows but yeah uh if you did it i
wouldn't i would blame it on someone
else yeah uh randy ramsey's that's right
next to basically where you're sitting
so you can't pass his desk up a little
bit yeah
he listens to the podcast like i've
stuck some books into his book
collection i don't know if he's noticed
really oh that's funny i love that
richard and i we were shooting something
earlier today
and we were looking for a canon 50
millimeter lens the really nice one that
i'm sure costed a lot of money and it
wasn't there and i was the last one who
used it so i was sweating i called you
out i was like because richard came up i
told him i i was like i haven't used
that camera i haven't used that camera
since like uh like almost before the
pandemic yeah so i was like but jake
films
and you were watching the entire time
you were waiting for me to mess up
um so anyway we're looking around for it
i was checking where we shot john lucan
said he'd put things away and i was like
okay
uh we're looking sure enough
it's in john luke's desk he's got it
he's got it in his desk i'm hoping
you'll never find it yeah i
know and that's why we called to disturb
his vacation today yeah and that's why
he tried to derail this yeah this is why
this didn't work
yeah i think i actually saw him messing
with this so it would be the setup so
it'd be difficult for me to start it
yeah
he wanted he wanted it to be difficult
for me
um anyway i have another topic here that
i came up with uh it's not a very good
one you may not even want to answer it
so i'm going to give you all five
seconds to think of a better topic and
then i'm gonna read this topic and then
we can decide
what you have for breakfast today that's
a no
now i wanna know the topic though well
maybe it's not bad okay
so so we all have produced a lot of
articles videos i think i have like
a thousand plus videos on gamespot or
something like that
holy [ __ ] video game content you've
created that you regret making that you
could just wipe from existence so i i i
figured this is kind of like inside
baseball but i figured
it would also be a good opportunity to
kind of talk about like you know some of
the processes
yeah let's do it you think this is okay
are we okay with this is there any
because are you okay with it the danger
is that you're probably gonna send
people to these yeah videos articles or
whatever you do that's probably gonna be
yeah whatever we'll we'll figure it out
we'll talk through why do you have do
you have one to start with oh i have so
many you will use the thing is like you
have a lineage
because like you you've like you've been
here from like the the associate you've
been here since an intern i always when
there wasn't even associates before we
dig into this when did y'all start to
work in the games industry like what
year so i know uh like
like a paycheck or like when did i start
writing and producing writing and
producing okay 2013 then 2013 okay um
i guess professionally
like actually working because like my
first real game industry job was is
gamespot
uh 2019. okay um yeah so three years
okay because i'm like i'm like probably
2019-ish too like three or so years so
i'm like i'm trying to think and i'm
like i don't know if i have much yet
though i mean yeah so i guess like
mine's funky because i was writing i was
like i was writing
for free i mean as like as volunteer for
websites that's what i'm counting
oh so i would think that would go back
back far that because for me i started
um
i almost want to say
2014
is when i start when i like like
was like i want to
learn how to do things i want to learn
how to write and i started like myself
in the deep end and started writing
without knowing how to write i had to
teach myself how to write during that
time it was bad yeah but i was writing
for websites like adventuregamers.com
do you remember
your first thing or maybe the first
memorable thing you wrote yeah i mean
the first thing i ever did was a review
on the game harvester
if you guys are familiar with that no
not at all
it's notoriously known as like the
goriest game ever made oh it was
interesting a point-and-click adventure
uh that i think was released in 94.96
because it was delayed a few years that
it's had it had a terrible terrible uh
like development period but it's an fmv
point-and-click oh okay um and it's
gratuitous
it is
almost disgusting it's a violent gross
uh
like
point-and-click adventure that's just
like filled with uh
really hard weird themes but it's also
like kind of like comedic and funny and
it's like it's a very it's interesting
it's an oxymoron of of of genres
um and i've actually been fascinated
with this game ever since i wrote their
review but my review is probably i don't
i don't even want to think yeah yeah
it's like it also was really long i
remember just writing a ridiculously
stupid long review and being like this
button does this and if you click here
it doesn't do that and how old are you
oh we're gonna date you a little bit no
it's fine um
25 24 i think
wait okay you you wrote you did this
review much later then right in my life
yeah okay first for a second i thought i
pictured like young kurt writing a
review for this
that's that's the thing i was like a bad
i was a musician an artist before i was
a writer and a video making boy so i was
never a good i was never like
at my start a writer i learned to be a
writer and i started like and i threw
myself into the deep end by being like i
want to learn how to write so yeah i
didn't i didn't actually get started
doing stuff
until like my mid early 20s but that was
after i worked at nintendo in qa yeah
which was a disaster
um no i've heard it's great there
oh yeah there's been an article yeah
there's an article it said everything
was just great yeah yeah i haven't no
problems i kind of don't know if i want
to read that article i might as somebody
who was qa there for almost a year i
read the summary of it that we posted as
like our news article linking to you
know the full report and just that was
enough that was enough yeah i'm
interested because i i had
problems like i've had things directed
one of the reasons why i'm kind of
grateful i left uh or was laid off
was because it just was not a good
environment yeah and i dealt with my own
my own you don't have to get to it yet
if you don't want to no no no i think i
told you this because like people it's
it's fine like people it was it wasn't
all it was just i'm a distinct person i
know this and i didn't necessarily fit
into that crowd when i walked into those
doors and i just like it was it just
took a while to be fine for me to find
my footing amongst the
400 some people who are working there so
anyways that's an off topic but yes
uh
yeah i wrote a review for the game
harvester it's a terrible game that i i
still think about to this day left an
impression interesting
i it it makes me think of hatred kind of
i don't know if you remember that game
no i do because in terms of how over the
top that trader was different because
that was like oh that was that was a
matter of shooter simulator basically
that was done in a cynical um way but
harvester is different because you
play as an amnesic kid who wakes up in
the middle of this like picturesque
1950s suburban town but like everyone's
a little twisted everyone's a little
weird but it's it's not done in a way
that's interesting it's so everything's
at the forefront it's like filled with
like
okay dark jokes dark humor innuendos
like from the start and uh it's just
like it actually tries to say something
kind of interesting in the end but
getting to that point to understand that
everything's the the point is deflated
by the time you get there yeah and it's
just it's just so is that game coming
out harvest stella that's the sequel
right yes okay cool okay i'm excited for
that one yeah yeah i'm gonna review it
i'm gonna write
full circle 1000 word review on it
um so i did a lot of news early on so i
don't remember what i first wrote
for game wise i guess when i was really
young not really young i don't know i
was like 14 i wrote a review for gears
of war
that didn't go anywhere i just wrote it
because i was bored one day
uh i love that that's like kind of
adorable though just like sitting down
like i'm gonna write this no one's gonna
read it so i did that for max payne when
i was like 11. okay i did i did write a
max p review it's like geocities website
like i could really stretch and be like
yeah i've been i've been in the games
industry writing for 20 years or
whatever
but that's what a lot of people do on
twitter i've noticed so they'll be like
game industry veteran of 10 years yeah
well i wrote a max payne
when i was 11. it was like no oh no
it wasn't in an actual part of like a
full-time publication until games yeah
but i will say the first review i didn't
get paid for this review but i got a
code for it was for the um
uh
oh man i can't believe i don't remember
the name it's one of your favorite games
ben's favorite games
what
grim fending grim fandango i wrote i
wrote a review for
uh i wrote a review for the the remaster
and that was the first code i got and i
loved it
i
i had a bug where i was stuck in an
elevator and had to restart the game
though which sucked oh okay um
i don't
yeah i remember restarting the game and
playing through like the first four or
five hours again just to get to that
point and i was terrified that i was
going to miss embargo because of that
which like i wasn't getting paid so i
probably should just go now [ __ ] it i'll
just do it when i can yeah but at the
time i was like this is a big deal i
have got oh that's sweet the first time
you get an embargo though is like it's
it's that cool little i don't know it is
a cool feeling it's like wow i have like
the tiniest little bit of power yeah
i remember getting rid of my first
embargo i remember getting code too
because i just went to double fine's
website and there was a press reach out
and i reached out and i was like i'm
reviewing it for this little site can we
get a code for this and they were and i
think it was tim shafer himself tim
schafer himself yeah sent you a letter
no i forgot
yeah but he like sent me an email and
was like here's a code was it parker it
wasn't tim it was
no absolutely not absolutely wasn't tim
but i remember
that happening like this is easier than
i thought and then you know everyone
else was like nah man
it's the whole thing of like if you walk
into a place looking like you know what
you're doing like people will just leave
you alone yeah yeah yeah you're right
yeah i don't know if i have anything
like you were talking about how people
will like say oh i've been working for
10 years because they'll count something
small i do the opposite i'm like
i'm the person who's been working like a
retail job for a year and i'm like i
don't know i'm new here
so
yeah i mean i guess this turned into the
first thing we ever did though well
we're gonna bring it back to
the thing we want wiped from the
internet okay
yeah i don't know i mean like okay i
have something that's uh kind of
relevant but not really because it's not
my career but it's embarrassing and it's
about video games um i used to write
fanfiction oh yeah the first one i ever
wrote um was before i knew what the
concept of fan fiction was it was on a
red floppy disk when i was
very young it had to have been like 99
um so i would have been like six years
old
um and i wrote about the ocarina of time
uh and so i wrote fanfiction about link
uh in the next adventure he would do so
like less romantic because i feel like
that's where you go with fan fiction is
like the romance thing and it was just
like no like i just really want them to
make a zelda game so i'm just gonna
write my own story about what happens to
link next i love it i wrote a dragon
ball z uh movie script when i was yeah
and then they stole it made majora's
mask nope
uh
no i said and then they stole my floppy
disk and made majora's mask so actually
i made majority thank you
six years old you just you're going
through it you start to write on uh
what's funny is i did the whole thing on
powerpoint because i wanted to be able
to put pictures in so people would
understand what i was talking about i i
remember making power points that were
video game themed then like show friends
like look at this look at this yeah and
they think i was weird the most i ever
did was like i would get graph paper and
like just try to pretend like i can
design my own levels be like this is how
they make levels i would do that yeah
yeah yeah like uh
i always had like you know young boy i'd
be like i'm a tough guy in an alleyway
i'm going to beat up some dudes so i had
like tough guy alleyway game
nice
i mean that's not bad if anybody wants
to make tough guy alleyway game just
call it that you can have it yeah that's
a good one do you want to give that away
are you sure
all right i take it back because jake
tucker is uh
uh don't make tough guy alleyway game
copyright here
for you there is a thing that you you
can if you say you know like uh it
belongs to me on some sort of recorded
piece of media that's that's me this is
here right now that's actually what
embracer group did
i own lord of the rings
power struggle i own lord of the rings
you can't take it away from me all right
send it to the judge it's just the
ultimate dibs we're gonna do lord of the
rings spin-off tough guy alleyway game
okay um but yeah so
i mean i guess i like that i don't know
if i'd erase that though that's pretty i
don't know
um but i would erase when i got a little
bit older um there was a site called
quizilla
and
yeah and you could do quizzes and stuff
on it as the name implies but it was
also huge for fan fiction before it got
shut down um and my friend wrote a
kingdom hearts fan fiction um that was
very long and filled with much
a lot of romance happening a lot
why
but i can't give i have an answer but
you continue i can't give her too much
[ __ ] because i also wrote fanfiction
that was romance centered and oh my god
i can't believe i'm saying what a rip
i wrote it was a love triangle between
tifa
vincent and cloud oh that makes perfect
sense and you know i it was fairly
popular before it was i you know i'm not
even gonna high five for that one
because it's okay i'll do i'll do a
little high five um but like you just
hold it there until then
i'm just like it's like sorry no high
five
like
it was so bad i'm pretty sure that like
reno at one point hit on her too it's
just everybody hitting on tifo which
like have you seen fifa make sense i
mean i don't remember who vincent is
vincent introduced africa oh my gosh the
because i played remake it's the love of
my life but i don't i don't know who
vincent is
that guy yeah he's so
we're not okay i can't do this but i'm
not going to hijack the time i'm talking
about vincent
and we should just read it
he is an ex-turk so he used to be in the
turks with like reno and rudens but he
didn't work at the same time as them
he's like 50 years older but he's been a
coffin um and because of being injected
with uh wait is this in seven or is this
in something else it's in seven okay
yeah he's in seven um and so he he is
not aged so he still looks like he's
like late twenties um he has long black
he looks like a vampire okay yeah he
wears like all red it's like a middle
it's a whole thing but he's great um he
will be i'm sure in rebirth i mean i
don't know i might like don't quote me
on that but i would assume
that one i mean that's what makes it
probably found they probably found it on
a floppy disk
so don't quote but they definitely took
my flop my red flap just yeah that's
actually the whole when i had the whole
setup of uh remake was just so that
rebirth can be a love triangle between
vince and clown cool so
so yeah that that should probably be
erased and thankfully quizilla died and
it was
we're good what about uh what's uh the
archive the wayback machine
oh should i try to bring it up
i i've gone to the wayback machine i
just couldn't figure it out and i was
like all right i've used this i've used
it for for a lot of research for um like
old episodes like yeah members i'm sorry
for when i was working on the show
remember when it was like a very very
good source to like dig through things
websites that didn't exist anymore or
things that were deleted uh also my
husband in the chat said tell them about
the shirt um i wish that i still had
this shirt um my dad for my birthday one
year got me a shirt that said i'm just
with this guy until vincent valentine is
single with an arrow and i threw it away
because i was so insulted but it was so
embarrassing and like now i wish more
than anything i had it because i would
wear it ironically but also not
ironically
anyway that's the end husband whom i
have a child with yeah
yeah
i mean it was like when i was 20
probably
but um yeah so
vincent valentine called me
from the red floppy desk in which you
live you can be the dad that stepped up
oh my god
i know the meme
i'm not the step dad i'm the daddy
stepped up
don't talk to me about memes
i'm in the wrong room i don't i don't i
normally me all of them go right over my
head
the only things i see are like i have
two friends who still send me memes and
i usually ignore them but i've seen that
one see
no actually they don't
they send it to callie but not to me
probably because they know i'd look at
it and be like i don't get it yeah
um kurt what do you want to what do you
want to erase from existence that you
that you have produced
it's i don't know if i'm in this i don't
know if i'm that ashamed
i feel like
you at least you you came into gamespot
already
pretty pretty good at hosting pretty
good at writing you know like thanks i i
was i was i was like a wet towel when i
started
uh i mean
because
maybe not a race but is there is there
like a mistake in a video that still
bugs you yeah there's i mean there's
definitely a mistake in a video i
actually mentioned earlier today it's
like so minor
and i know like compared to
the thousand some videos you've made
you'd be like dude whatever but it does
linger with me because there's a big
deal for me to be able to do it uh it
was when i did the psychonauts 2 preview
so that was like the first time that i
was like
i've written i had done reviews in the
past for gamespot
um
but this is my first time like doing a
preview
doing an interview with like
what's that tea tree montgomery and tim
schaefer from double fine and then also
like
capturing the game and doing the preview
edit by myself and now this whole thing
was like i'm doing this by myself i want
to be in the video i wanted to like make
an effort to try and put a little bit
more personality into this and how we do
these this is so unbelievably stupid and
minor but i i exposed it's like really
inside baseball nerdy video stuff i
exported it at 24 frames per second
and like so the gameplay is
and i never noticed it and no one ever
really called out during the qa process
and when it went up like all the
comments were like man this game looks
bad the frame rate sucks and i had to
like be like this is my fault this is
that makes completely mortified at
developers seeing my particular preview
and being like
don't give them anything because they
make our game look bad and i just was i
mean of course then i ended up doing the
review and edited the review myself and
i learned my lesson there and i know
better now um but yeah it's just like a
minor silly it's a minor thing that i
just like
doesn't look good like literally and you
know for yeah yeah i just felt really
like damn it
so i wish i could change that game frame
rate is kind of because
we we typically shoot things richard
shoots things in 24
like 23.98 or whatever it is
then we capture gameplay 30 60 30 60
sometimes more usually one of those two
but then sometimes when you do videos
where you're on camera and then you also
have zoom which zoom is like
it says it's 20 but it's actually like
10 frames a second because the quality
is [ __ ] and then you throw them all into
one timeline and then you
hit x4 it it's like it
forces things to different frame rates
and sometimes yeah i mean i learned my
lesson and i know that totally probably
so it's just but it's not as
embarrassing or as spicy as i'm sure
people wanted to be but that's something
that i've done at gamespot where i was
like man what a ding dong yeah
i
i
[Laughter]
yeah yeah you brought up with this one
huh where do i start uh i feel like i
said the bar is so like incriminally
whatever i well
i to be fair i have been making videos
at gamespot since 2015. the first
feature i remember doing was
a
that i voiced was
five tips on how to beat witcher 3 on
death march mode or whatever and i think
that video is decent but i sound like
i'm asleep
oh my god do you really want to erase
that though no no i don't i don't think
i want to erase that i'd like to listen
to it i did a bunch of news updates and
a lot of mistakes went through those
because there was a period where i was
asked to do five news updates a day
which we don't really do anymore but it
was like
minute and a half two minute long videos
about news stories that we'd turn into a
video and we'd throw in articles
um and i had a good amount of mistakes
in those i mean not a whole lot
considering how much i did but the ones
the mistakes i had i remember there was
one i don't remember what it was exactly
that i had done but some guy got really
mad at justin for
being the vo even though i wrote it
justin haywald who worked here a while
ago
um
and then another video i forgot to
source
some
footage from a doom mod
and total biscuit went after when after
me for not sourcing this this gameplay
of a mod
even though i talked about the mod in
the game like they're in in the video
itself but i remember getting a lot of
[ __ ] online for that and that was like
my first couple months here so i wish i
could probably just get rid of that um
to be fair i did like
i don't know if i necessarily work
things out with him because i had no way
to contact him but other people did and
was able to work things out and uh
uh after after the fire that hit my
house he donated a bunch of money to my
family for some reason i mean so like
i know a lot of people don't get don't
didn't necessarily vibe with him but i
have respect for him despite the fact
that
he just ripped into this intern who had
no idea what he was doing and had never
been in the industry and i was like man
games media
um but i think that there's not a lot of
grace extended yeah especially
especially with social media it's like
you messed up i'm not gonna learn
context i'm just gonna bury you roast
you um
when there was a god of war video i did
that
even thinking about it makes me cringe
it was like it was after i was watching
a bunch of uh game makers toolkit stuff
and i was like i want to do an essay
like that so i tried to do one about god
of war's story and it is so
up its own ass and it's so cringy i was
still in film school so i was like i'm
gonna use some of my film school
knowledge to make this more interesting
and just show david lynch for no reason
just just make it black and white and
yummy
it was it was just very nice just show a
corner of a wall yeah for a solid minute
straight it was just like kratos is
really internalizing his uh his guilt at
this moment you can tell by the way he
swings his axe at this tree he's sick
and
i don't know why i thought it was good
immediately i published it and i was
like
that may have been the dumbest video
i've ever made wait is it through
gamespot it's through gamespot yeah
look dude it's i'm i i think like it's
stuff like that that gets me excited
like anybody who wants to look back at
the things that you use that somebody
used to make
grow up like you've made bad stuff like
go back and look at it and be proud of
the thing you you become like that
you're able to look and be like that was
silly yeah but like i actually kind of
get like a kick out of keeping it online
and like being like yeah you can live oh
yeah i think yes i was but like now look
at me i'm like
a different kind of dingus yeah that's a
good way to put it i looked up something
like this is a much like
lighter example but i remember i was
searching for like a tweet that i had um
posted or something recently i don't
remember what it was about
um but you know how you can type in like
your handle and then like a word that
you know is in the tweet to try to like
find it i typed in like a tweet from
like 2011 or something like that that i
wrote popped up and it was something
like so excited to see the new marvel
movie blah blah blah i don't even know
it was just something that was like i
read it and i'm just like oh god that
was so cringy but you know but i was
excited like little jessica was excited
you know so like people need to chill
out yeah on yourself and the world never
i agree like to to be fair i'm not too
beat up about it anymore but i get it
it's it's more like and i don't care
that it's out there like i think it's
good that it's there i just i just look
back at that video in particular and i
was like that is not me
i was trying
to be something i'm not for this video
to be fair
when i write and produce videos for
gamespot i'm still not super confident
in my own voice like i don't know
like some days i feel this way other
days i don't but that video in
particular like
after that was done i was like that's
not me hey man you would have never
known i didn't play foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
it was it was that uh when i was done
writing it i was like this is this isn't
what i want to make yeah this isn't it
yeah
that's cool though like like really
you can't you can't grow without doing
some cringy stuff like you gotta you
gotta do it even when i even embrace the
cringe i uh
even i have just a hard time looking
back at stuff i was doing when i first
started here like
i have a hard time watching the few like
the the beginning of true fiction like
just because i just
that was the first thing i made for us
that was in the first show it was like
my first time like working with a team
of people a group of people and like in
my mind i was like yeah i mean i host it
it works in the way that i was like
deliberately trying to host it like rod
sterling or um
or robert stack so it makes sense in a
way but it's like
it's what i'm trying to say is it's hard
to look back at anything basically yeah
like something like uh
like i look back my first review for us
was deadly premonition
um and what a hell of a review
was that was my first one but like it's
still i could tell i was just trying too
hard i was thinking too hard about it um
i still stick by guns with what i said
about that game but yeah in terms of how
i wrote it just like i would write that
a little differently now yeah
it's a learning process that's how you
get better mm-hmm by looking back and be
like
don't do that again idiot i know the
kratos
anger can be seen through the veins of
his bicep when he picks up his swords
what are they called
axes acts they're little there are those
oh the the other things he's got the
little things around them
yeah i don't know that's called the
gamer fan over here yeah
uh well it's good we talked about god of
war though because that's a big game and
we can put that in the tags so people
will yes we talk about the god of war
and his the the depression of his butt
cheeks
yeah
uh okay moving on to the question of the
week this will probably be the last
thing we talk about but this like i said
was from maria serious business on the
gamespot discord what game slash game
series deserves a spin off a dragon age
tactics game a metal gear visual novel a
dark souls game
what would be your choice of game and
genre
i knew this was coming and i didn't
think of anything for it so i have one
okay
but i think it's because i was once
asked a question like what would you
like an anime spin-off and i kind of
think my answer might be the same
because i'm so obsessed with the world
of this game and i just want to see more
things of it it's paradise killer i
would love to see
um
a spin-off game of paradise killer
almost in like the way of like something
like coffee talk i would love because
like the g so i don't know if either one
of you played paradise killer i played
paradise killer but i don't know i
haven't played coffee talking okay so
like you know paradise killer like the
thing that i love about that game is
like you see it at the tail end of this
world that's about to end and you only
get to interact with the last people who
are left there before like everyone goes
off so there's like this whole
whole like you could just like feel that
there was a world that was made here
that you just get to see the remnants of
um and so coffee talk is a game
about uh where you just play as a
barista making drinks for person after
person after person who comes in and
like it's just you just learned their
stories the story of the game as the
individual stories who were walking in
as your customers
i'm making this up as i'm talking by the
way okay i was like i want paradise
killer but i don't know what it would be
and i just thought i was like but being
a bartender in the world of paradise
killer would be such an amazing way to
like learn the actual characters of that
game and world without being it tied
into like a murder mystery like the
actual game was so that's my answer
thanks for submitting the question that
i was not scared of paradise killer
you're scared of it yeah i don't know
why like the aesthetic of it like
there's something about it that's so
deeply unsettling to me it reminds me of
like my nightmares
which is such a weird maybe that's why i
like it yeah probably like i don't know
like i
i don't know what it is about that game
but i seriously started and like and
just how
it made me like sick it just it reminded
me of my nightmare so it's so weird like
so like neon gods and like yeah i don't
i don't know what it is it was like the
white marble and like the pools and like
how ornate everything was like and how
empty everything was there's just
something it reminds me of like
seriously like some of the worst
nightmares i've ever had i've been like
sorry no it's it's just like a funny
weird thing because i have so many
friends who love that game and tell me
oh you gotta play it you gotta play it
and i'm like i want to but it creeps me
out so bad i would rather play like
outlast or something at home
because like it creeps me out it does
have some gruesome scenes on it too
there are there are like moments of
horror for me yeah but in a way that's
like you know that uh but not in like
exploring the world yeah it's so weird i
don't know why it's just like it's empty
and quiet and eerie and like there's
just something so
city pop yeah it's just so unsettling to
me and i don't know why it's totally
okay but um i'm trying to think of what
my
uh spin-off would be i don't know i'll
toss it to jake to go
choose your own adventure romance novel
with fifa vincent cloud yeah there you
go oh that's perfect honestly
um mobile sp mobile
choose your own adventure romance novel
yeah of those three characters pay pay
you have to pay for the sexiest options
um
there you go
like what like how cropped do you want
tifa's crop top yeah
how spikes do you want you probably
charge more for that people will pay for
that yeah
you could probably especially italy yes
yes
wait right have you guys don't know
about that the whole like
okay we can talk after the show
it's have you it's like so i guess last
year right the italian senate
accidentally struggled with that video
yeah okay okay or no it was earlier this
year they accidentally streamed final
fantasy vii porn like during a
government meeting so it's just tifa
going at it um mama mia yeah there was
like so much fan art of like tifa
wearing the italian flag oh i mean like
speaking to my roots like
it was so funny but um yeah
wow
i didn't know if i should bring up uh
inappropriate videos on the podcast but
i'm glad i did that's okay i think it's
after dark matter
i remember like early days of after dark
one of the episodes went into a
pornography
tangent i thought
probably cool
yeah probably good to know that michael
shouts out hentai when he's oh yeah oh
yeah that's true okay if michael's been
out i can't say anything more michael's
been yeah
you've you're fine um
i
the other i wasn't even the other day it
was earlier this year i had lunch with
michael
and um we had a discussion about if
snake girls or cat girls were sexier
um for like 20 minutes so
i think he was playing uh shinigami
tensai three or whatever it was it was
the newer one that came out and there
were snake girls
that game's all you know oh yeah yeah i
know michael's all hot and heavy in that
game
yeah old news
old news
snake girls i'm not saying they're
sexier i'm just saying snake girls
i got nothing
i can't think do i have to come up with
one for you too no i'm i'm i'm trying to
think that there i i
i have some really basic ones that
aren't interesting no i don't even have
any i don't have any
uh i just came up with i i did yeah i
want more tactics games in existence
in general
so the the one
that that comes to mind is like
a a
pokemon game designed with multiplayer
in mind from the start you know like a a
multiplayer co-op pokemon game
scarlet and violet has kind of headed
that direction but i don't know if it's
as grand as like i picture in my head
yeah but that's not that interesting i
feel what about what about a witcher
point-and-click adventure
uh
i feel like that could work
that that'd be cool we got a dope
witcher spin-off though with
thronebreaker i don't know if anyone's
played that but that game was really
good and that's kind of a point okay
okay okay
um
there's it's like half card game in half
making decisions and and story beats and
stuff which is quite good i thought of
what i want i want a hades dating some
perfect there we go that's a good one
yeah
yeah
i feel like that was like yeah that's
ripe for it i don't you don't even need
to explain it no done yeah
bam that's it cool i just want to date
the gods in hades yeah that's fair yeah
yeah i yeah i know i'm kind of like man
maybe i should have said paradise killer
dating soon yeah anything with a dating
sim it's it's going to be fun so you
know
unless it's the last of us dating son
oh my god
that's what that's yeah that's that's
what you want that's what i want
yes
yeah well that would be terrifying
absolutely terrifying
on a nice little golf trip yes
all right well i think that about does
it for episode 158 of gamespot after
dark thank you for sticking with us
we're sorry about the technical
difficulties jean-luc will be back next
week so things will be
going well the lens thief the lens thief
the lens thief himself will show his
face in this office once again
um kurt anything you want to plug before
we go
just like i i always feel weird be like
look at me follow me i know i i just
want you to like i always kind of say
like just be aware that you're enjoying
the stuff you're enjoying
what like be like i want to tell people
like go because like just have a
conscious awareness of the stuff that
like you're like having a good time with
yeah yeah if you're playing the game
just be aware like yeah i'm having a
good time playing a game
you know that's always such a good
feeling yeah like when you finally when
it clicks and you're like i'm
comfortable i feel good look out for
those moments and if you do i mean i
guess it's just you know
at kurt underscore in davina
but hey
any any videos coming up oh
i don't care about socials oh sweet good
me neither um i mean i guess yeah sure
there's a on um
august 22nd which is monday uh i have a
video coming out
uh about the redesign that saved death
loop that's that's what i was trying to
get you to say oh see i was i was like i
was just like i just want people to have
a good time well they can have a good
time watching your video because it's
very good and i've seen it oh thank you
i don't know i don't know if i knew you
watched it i didn't leave any comments
because that's the way to go there were
already comments in there and i watched
it three days after it was up oh
brilliant well yeah if uh but if if i
had caught it the day of i would have
gutted the no i'm just kidding
i mean chris morrison's edited it so he
can take it uh yeah with that said i
have a video we by chris morris and
myself partners in crime i have a video
coming out on monday about death loop
it's a part of a kind of a series that
we've put together called not a feature
which is basically uh
it tells the stories when
of development stories that have gone
catastrophically wrong
but
in very many ways and how they kind of
came back from it so we have one on the
forgotten city which came out a few
weeks ago about the redesign that broke
the forgotten city
um we also have one on weird west we
have one on boulder's gate three which
is a fantastic episode i'm really proud
of and the first one which is the b that
broke skyrim
um
so yeah if you're interested go watch
those and then i'm working on a video
about playing mobile games for a week so
yeah good luck with that thank you jess
anything you want to plug uh i want to
plug your god of war video
no no no no no we're not doing this
um
i i really the thing is there's 38 000
videos on game spots yeah and like we
covered god of war pretty hard so i'm
confident they're not gonna find it
anyway
there will be one person just three
thousand seven hundred yeah if you say
that and someone's gonna drop a link in
chat right away
this you
um
but yeah i wrote i published something
today on
boy games and i'm gonna leave it as
vague as that because
look it up i guess
um no but i'm actually i think it was a
really cool
um no you're fine um and uh what else
what else have i done lately i don't
know a game i reviewed called right now
no that was a great article today um
yeah i don't know uh other things will
happen but i probably can't talk about
them so
uh i
am working on a lot of different things
at once so nothing is getting done as it
normally does but
uh in a couple days you'll probably see
a video review for a big game once
that's done i will be working on an
updated review for the last of us
part one
the remaster remake
sure and then and then yeah one day i'll
finish this artifor video
you will
take a while i'm counting on it
yeah i'm not honestly painting it for
you from do it for me i just hope the
last of us pulls like a final fantasy 7
and you just get to the end and it's
like it's just a totally different no or
it's just the third of the game it's
just yeah it's just the third of the
game and yeah yeah
it cuts two hours into last of us part
one part two is coming out every
birthday yeah in three years
all right we will see y'all next time
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]